how you guys doing so you heard the uh
really sad unfortunate news
uh
mufti uthman
who ended up being confronted
and i think he was coming from the
dentist and the guy followed him and he
started like you know using some
profanities
again what's up
you know you think i'm scared of you
you know and then next thing you know we
find out we see a picture and uh shake
our stabs so how did he get stabbed
we're going to be going over how he
probably you know the direction of the
knife how and some good um you know the
best is to avoid these situations you
know fighting someone with a knife but
we got some mean ali got something for
you after this
um that you guys can go ahead and um
look at and hopefully if you're in a
life-threatening situation you can use
this technique but you know ali this is
ali kedakov for those uh who watched
that program before
uh professional former professional
uh fighter
retired
that's it yeah just imagine if you had
some
jewish clergy some christian clergy
and they ended up being if the role was
reversed if you had some crazy
muslim go and stab let's see some
christian clergy with a knife
why why is the media silent on this
it's the same way silent with what's
going on in syria and sudan and all
other countries you know i mean i have
no idea
the way they represent the ukraine and
stuff like this yeah we said for that
you know any war is bad
but you have to be uh equal to everyone
you know if the christian will be
stabbed like this is probably going to
be all over the news
but now the sheikh will you know get
stabbed and i didn't even know that i
know this from you
because this is nowhere yeah it's crazy
right yeah yeah so uh yeah you mentioned
uh ukraine obviously it's really sad
anytime these events happen war
uh prussia and all these things but it's
you know the uh the double standard the
is
hypocrisy
it's just mind blowing exactly
have to be equal both ways you know what
i mean so i guess uh that's the question
where is the media on this you have a
person of the islamic faith the muslim
one who is surrendered and submitted to
one and only one god who's out there you
know calling people to the way of jesus
to the pure monotheism what is it do you
not like his tone his message what he's
calling to and now the guy gets all you
know in his face and goes on the attack
with a knife
and the media is silent so the question
is if this was
christian clergy if this was uh any
other religious clergy man and now a
muslim would have done some crazy which
this would be unacceptable
would the media be
covering it leave us in the comments
below would they and why aren't they
covering it now
why why aren't there why isn't there a
manhunt for this guy a manhunt
i have no idea nobody even find the guy
right i don't think so where's the
manhunt this should be all over the
news and
all right so that's the question what do
you guys think leave in the comments
below why is there not a man hunt for
the guy who stabbed a muslim clergyman a
mufti
and
let's get into
this video that we did
showing
how
mufti uthman how he possibly got
stabbed and how he possibly could defend
himself and how he could possibly yes
defend himself with this move that me
and ali kadurov about to get into hope
you enjoy it
so we're going to go over this knife
defense this looks like you know the
pictures you guys seen with mufti uthman
getting stabbed it looks like something
like this doesn't it
so we're going to go ahead and
just a quick disclaimer this is very
important when i teach any kind of
weapons disarmament defense it's really
a bad idea to engage with someone who
has a weapon who has a knife the best
thing is to avoid these situations at
all costs to run off but if you're
trying to survive and you're cornered
and now you got nowhere else to go and
somebody's got a knife
then there's some things that we can do
now from here
now there's a few things i'm going to
try to anticipate what the person's
going to do so either if they got a
knife they're going to be in this range
here right if it's underhand the person
is going to be coming from here
somewhere like this they're not going to
be trying to stab you like this if it's
from here then same thing this is the
kind of ranges that we're working with
now as many of you've seen
with my
bandage or whatever he had he was
pointing to it seemed like he was he was
stabbed from the bottom right so it's
good to assume it's safe to assume that
he probably the person who attacked him
had the knife coming from the downward
angle so let's go ahead and work a knife
defense if you're trapped you're trying
to survive again it's a bad idea to go
up against someone's a knife best to get
out but there's some things that we can
do
so assuming that it's coming from the
bottom it's going to be this grip
so we got ali cado cough
professional
retired professional fighter here with
us
he's going to go ahead and go underhand
okay so the details are as follows as
you notice from here he's coming under
hand i'm going to go ahead and block
yes
and i don't want him to pull the knife
back so notice my other hand as he comes
in yes comes over because i don't want
if i'm just blocking here he's going to
come back again and strike with the
knife so i'm going to put both my hands
in position boom one to block the knife
trying to penetrate okay the other one
is going to come over and i'm going to
pull
pull him towards me
and come around here
from here this hand can grab the hair
can he grab here by his jacket okay
while my other hand is going to come up
coming up to go ahead
and have him
give up
drop the knife and then
hopefully we can get out of this bad
situation any any advice you want to
give uh
coming up against uh a weapon go round
fast
run fast all right please be with you
salaam